[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is cs50
then this is lecture 6 and you recall
that last week we introduced web
programming by way of HTML and CSS or at
least the building blocks just we don't
actually have the ability to program yet
it's just markup HTML and CSS was
stylisation thereof but we introduced
this metaphor last week of a protocol
called tcp/ip and we related it to of
course an envelope and on this envelope
virtually on the front was at least two
pieces of information and if anyone
remembers what were those two pieces of
information in the to field someone else
who we didn't hear from recently yeah
yeah an IP address a numeric address
that uniquely identifies your computer
and someone else's computer and one
other thing if you remember oh come on
who's like two minutes ago okay yeah a
port number so another number shorter
number that's just the number like 80 or
443 referring to wet HTTP or HTTPS or
other numbers like 25 for email and the
like and so together these unique
addresses allow you to send information
to not only a specific computer but a
specific service running on that
computer and in order to actually
request information from that server
there's this other protocol called HTTP
hypertext Transfer Protocol this is
what's inside of the envelope so when
the server opens it up metaphorically
looks inside this is the command that
that server reads in order to decide
what it should actually respond with and
so this request here is telling the
server otherwise known as dub-dub-dub
dot example.com in this particular
example to send back what exactly in its
own envelope to me and my laptop if I
were to request this a specific webpage
and someone else which web page
specifically presumably yeah so
index.html which we said last week just
tends to be the default file name on a
server for a web page that's just
selected by default and it doesn't have
to be called this but it's a human
convention and the rest of this is just
a verb saying literally get me that file
this is just telling the server what
version of HTTP I speak so that humans
can improve it in Mato and upgrade it
over time but this would tell the server
to return index.html
meanwhile we saw more sophisticated get
queries when we started talking about
Google and any website that has not just
a front-end like HTML and CSS but also a
back end and a back end is where the
logic is where the server is and the the
interesting worked ultimately and so
this slash search indicates some kind of
software running on Google servers as of
last week that simply responds to
requests and what did question mark Q
equals cats do or represent in that
demonstration
yeah user input so the question mark
just says that's it for the file name or
the URL here comes the users input Q is
just the literally the HTTP parameter or
input that Larry and Sergey founders of
Google 20 years ago decided would
represent the users input Q for query
equal just means that query that the
human typed in was cat but the human
doesn't even have to type this in once
you understand HTTP if you really wanted
to be kind of a nerd you could go to WWE
comm slash search question mark Q equals
cats and it would induce the search for
you because at the end of the day that's
all the browser is doing when you have
these web forms that you now have the
ability to create it's just automating
the process of generating these HTTP
messages now the server hopefully
responds with a message you never ever
actually see HTTP 200 which literally
means okay of course many of us have
seen numbers other than 200 appear like
what 404 which means file not found now
why the humans decided years ago to tell
human to tell other humans what that
number merit code is I mean that is an
uninteresting detail but the world for
whatever reason has revealed in many
websites 404 but it just means the same
thing everything is not okay a file was
not found you might see something else
like this we saw this with Harvard in
fact curiously that Harvard had moved
permanently now Harvard was responding
to certain queries with HTTP 301 x' in
order to achieve what feature or effect
what yeah redirection so this is kind of
a low-level way of describing it but 301
even though it says moved permanently
that's a more technical hint to the
browser saying Harvard moved not to
whatever URL you just came from but to
this URL specifically and now hard
was probably if you recall redirecting
me from what URL if I wasn't already at
that URL where might I have been so
maybe calm if they actually own multiple
domains and we're redirecting that could
work what else yeah yeah maybe I just
typed in HTTP and Harvard in the
interest of security wants to force my
browser to request me request this page
again via HTTP sometimes a website might
prepend the www if you haven't typed it
in or you can be redirected most
anywhere in fact if you go to see a
swifty zone website by just typing cs50
that Harvard edu watch the URL you'll be
redirected to a more specific page
depending on the time of year so we use
these tricks as well 404 not found might
look like this
but inside deeper that metaphorical
envelope is the actual contents of the
web page so you get back not only these
HTTP headers as they're called in the
top of the response so to speak but you
also get back HTML yet another language
we looked at this one actually a
language but not a programming language
these tags tell the browser exactly what
to do in to render um we introduced this
style tag though what did that allow us
to do that HTML alone did not yeah use
CSS to beautify the site and just make
it nicer HTML for the most part is about
structure and about tagging the contents
of your web page in a way that the
browser finds helpful but CSS is really
for the users benefit at the end of the
day and his or her eyes because it
really lets you control font size and
positioning and lower level stuff that
you might have started tinkering with
with the most recent problem set now
we'd proposed that you probably
shouldn't just start typing CSS inside
of your HTML page because it's just a
little harder to maintain as your
examples get more sophisticated so you
might factor it out and odds are you did
this for the problem set because when
making a home page if you have the same
CSS Styles across multiple files it
would be pretty silly and inefficient to
copy and paste them again and again when
you can factor them out like this lastly
we looked at JavaScript last time
another programming language that's
super similar to C at least at first
glance but it actually gets rid of a lot
of the lower-level headaches like
pointers and memory addresses in that
that we've struggled with in recent
weeks
but most important was how we used it so
you can consider a web page like this as
once it's loaded by your browser's just
being a tree structure thinking back a
couple weeks to our discussion of data
structures and each of these nodes in
the tree we saw in JavaScript can be
manipulated and via that very simple
principle writing code that modifies
this existing tree in the computer in
the browser's memory means you can make
much more dynamic things like Gmail and
Facebook and any number of websites that
are constantly changing you did not do
this yet for the problem set you made
static web pages just by hard coding
HTML and CSS but starting next week once
we have thanks to this week the
vocabulary of Python will you start to
make things more dynamic and then even
bring back into play JavaScript bringing
all these various threads together and
to include the JavaScript recall we used
either a script tag at the top or we
factored it out to a file or in some
cases it's necessary or beneficial to
move it down to the bottom of the file
or factor it out like that but more on
that down the road so many questions on
last week or on HTTP HTML CSS or tcp/ip
no yeah good question so in what cases
would you put the script tag up at the
top versus at the bottom if the code
you're writing in JavaScript manipulates
the Dom the tree that I had on the
screen just a moment ago the catch is
that that tree needs to exist when your
code is executed so if you for instance
have JavaScript code up here in the head
of your page but the nodes in the tree
the tags that you want to manipulate and
changing things to red to green to blue
like we did last week or making things
blink or down here in the page you can't
write your code up here and have it
changed things in the page down here
because it's happening out of order so
similar in spirit to see where things
have to happen in the right order if you
want to change something down here your
code needs to at least be down here or
you need to use some fancier techniques
to say I'm gonna write my code up here
but wait a few seconds before executing
it until the whole bud page is loaded so
for the most of the examples we looked
at this was not an issue but we'll come
back to this
before long all right so let's now take
the same approach that we did last time
of introducing one language by way of
another you'll recall of course that we
started the whole semester with scratch
and then we transitioned a few weeks
back now to see last week we made some
comparisons with JavaScript let's do the
same thing briefly with Python but then
spend more time at the keyboard
comparing the two to see what actually
is different about these so why in
another language though first we have
scratch C JavaScript Python
not to mention HTML and CSS for
different purposes like why do we have
all of these darn languages already why
didn't the humans just decide that's it
we're all using scratch we're all using
C or JavaScript or Python what's perhaps
the intuition behind that why are there
so many damn languages not to mention in
this one course yeah say once more yeah
different ones are good for different
things and this probably goes without
saying for something like scratch right
it's so visual it's so graphical and
animated like it makes sense that the
puzzle pieces are that the language
itself is based on puzzle pieces and
dragging and dropping
so maybe languages are tailored to
certain applications but is that let is
that true for C Python in JavaScript
which are all text-based languages we'll
see ok different levels of abstraction
good
okay good bringing back to abstraction
does make sense see is indeed like very
low-level literally having the ability
to manipulate memory and via pointers
and so forth and that's great because
you can do anything you want with the
computer but it comes at great risk and
great cost one the cost is human time
like it's just painful to write that
kind of code sometimes to it also it's
also very risky because if you make a
mistake even a simple mistake the whole
computer can crash and we didn't see
examples of this but you can make the
your code vulnerable to a hacker if he
or she is able to somehow exploit a
memory related bug and read all of the
passwords in your program or something
like that so with great power comes
great responsibility it's kind of the
mantra of C down here but JavaScript we
saw allows us to do things a little more
high-level like there were no pointers
there was no memory we didn't talk about
things at that level we talked about
things at the level of a tree a Dom in
memory and changing colors and and
positioning of things on the screen and
that's indeed a higher level now python
is not necessarily even web-centric it's
more of a multi-purpose language people
use python to write command-line
programs like we will soon at the
keyboard like we've been doing with c
you can also though use it as we'll see
next week to generate other languages so
next week we will write code in Python
the language we're about to see to
generate another language HTML and CSS
some of you probably noticed in your
home pages that you had some redundancy
you probably had similar tags or similar
structure may be a similar menu across
pages Python and other languages will
let us factor that out and generate
those commonalities a lot more easily
among many other things and it's also
arguably easier and faster to write
because it comes with so many more
features as we will soon see so in fact
you know what let me do this let me go
ahead and open up cs50 IDE let me go
ahead and create a new file and out of
curiosity of our recent problem sets
what was maybe among the most
challenging programs you've written ok
crack was a good one what else
resize recover yeah definitely the
forensics ones and more people probably
did recover and resize so let's take
resize for example so let me go ahead
and write a program in a file called
resize PI for python instead of dot c
and see if we can't spend what few hours
couple days as you probably didn't see
resize well let me go ahead and do this
I'm gonna go ahead and let's see first
I'm gonna import some features that just
come with Python and I'm gonna go ahead
and say from sis import Arg V and I'm
gonna go ahead and also do Maya from PIL
import image don't know what yet what
these are will tease this apart in a
moment but then let me just do a check
if the length of rather if the length of
Arg V does not equal four I'm gonna go
ahead and exit for the user and say the
usage of this program is Python resize
da PI and in file out file so even
though some of this should look cryptic
at the moment there's some commonalities
are V you recall from C and this usage
string that we printed out whenever
anything went wrong that looks very
similar in spirit to C and what did we
do in resize if you implemented resize
like the less comfy version to increase
the size of things you probably declared
a variable like N and got sis dot or
rather our V bracket 1 to get access to
it I'm gonna go ahead and convert that
or cast that to an int you probably had
an in file variable that gave you access
to like argh v2 you probably had an out
file variable that gave you access to
our v3 and so forth
and it turns out in Python if you know
what I can actually use a library code
that other people have written let me
come up with a variable called in image
like in file this is my input image and
that's gonna equal image dot open
because I want to open this thing called
in file and then the width let me get
the width in the height of the existing
image by doing input image size and then
let me go ahead and make a new image out
image I'll call it which is going to
equal the input image calling a resize
function and doing the width times n
which is the number the human probably
typed in an H a height times n which is
the number the human typed in then let
me go ahead and just save the out file
as follows out file okay done problem
set 3
tada okay either really exciting or
really really disheartening perhaps
right so with the right language as you
say can you solve problems so much more
easily now I'm being a little
disingenuous because I'm also leveraging
what's called a library and we had
access to these in C and undoubted that
we could have dug a little deeper on the
Internet into other people's available
code and found maybe a library for
bitmap files but notice that there is no
dealing with padding now there's no
dealing with arrays there's no dealing
with memory because I'm using the right
tool for the job and if I wrote this
code correctly and let me cross my
fingers that I didn't make any typos let
me go ahead here and get myself a copy
of smiley which I brought with me so
that was the tiny little image from last
week let me go ahead and open this in
the IDE smiley super small just a few
pixels there and let me go ahead now and
run Python which we'll see why in a
moment
resize let's increase this by a factor
of 10 increasing smiley and call it out
dot BMP now let me go ahead and open out
dot BMP and voila it indeed seems to
work right no funky colors no like weird
sizes no padding no padding of all
things
it's just now Python so you can probably
glean some of the logic that's going on
here but some of it certainly should and
probably does look magical so let's use
today the tease this apart and
appreciate not only what you can do with
another language like Python but how
it's similar and different and how it
actually is built upon something like C
so let's do some comparisons first so
that we can see that it's not a huge
stretch to introduce yet another
language so quickly so recall that in
scratch if we wanted to set a variable
like counter to zero
you might simply do something like this
setting it equal to zero at left in C we
would do the same thing here at the
right in JavaScript this instead looked
a little different what did we do in
JavaScript yeah we used let instead
because we don't specify explicitly the
type but we do need to tell the computer
let me have this variable called counter
in Python it's going to be that so we've
gotten rid of the type still we've
gotten rid of any mention of lets or
another keyword and we've gotten rid of
perhaps most gratifyingly
my colons are gone no more semicolons
and no more curly braces in the way
you've seen them thus far
so that was C JavaScript and now Python
so how about something like this in pipe
scratch if you want to increment a
counter by one you would use a block
like this in C we would do the same on
the right here in code in JavaScript did
it look any different on the right no
you probably haven't had a case you
haven't had occasion to use this yet but
one of the sort of revelations of
JavaScript was that's also JavaScript it
was identical something like this though
is Python so it's almost the same but
I've gotten rid of the semicolon but the
logic is exactly the same set counter on
the left equal to whatever it is on the
right plus one additional value what
about this this in C had what effect
incrementing the variable so this is
exactly the same it's sort of a nice
shorthand notation for doing counter
equals counter plus one which just gets
a little tedious to type we had that
same syntax in JavaScript and you can
probably guess in Python what's it going
to look like same thing minus the
semicolon all right so a pretty nice
pattern so far languages just keep
getting trimmer and trimmer if you will
in C recall that we could just do plus
plus which was another trick for
automating that same process javascript
allows for the same and if you really
like the syntax I can't show you a slide
for Python doesn't exist can no longer
do plus plus so we're paying a price the
author of Python did not include this in
the language but that's ok we at least
have this one which is not too horrible
so what else do we look at last time an
if condition like this comparing if X is
less than Y and C it looks like this in
JavaScript it looks like this same thing
in Python it looks like this so gone are
the curly braces added is a colon and
what you don't see yet is that
indentation is going to be important so
any of you have been a little fast and
loose with style 50 and like we've seen
it office hours all of your code however
many lines you've written for whatever
reason is all aligned on the left and
nothing is actually indented now pythons
not going to tolerate that Python
requires indentation for logic and so
this is actually a stylistic feature of
the language it forces you to adopt good
visual stylistic habits because the code
just won't run if you haven't indented
it properly so any
thing that's gonna happen if X is less
than Y needs to be indented say four
spaces underneath that : what else have
we seen in CR in scratch we had this
block four ifs and else's and see it
looks like this in JavaScript it looks
like this in Python it's gonna look like
this albeit with indentation below each
of those colons how about this when we
had three-way a fork in the road if else
if else in C it looks like this
JavaScript looked the same
in Python looks a little funky it's
gonna look like this l if but three
colons this time too
what else we also looked at forever
loops in scratch in C and in JavaScript
you could use exactly the same syntax in
Python almost the same gone or the curly
braces added is the colon and the slight
subtlety if you noticed true and false
are now proper nouns if you will
capital T capital F is necessary to
write how about a for loop so in scratch
we could very easily say repeat this 50
times C and JavaScript is a little
pedantic and that you have to initialize
an increment and check both C and
JavaScript take that same approach
although in JavaScript we of course used
let instead of int Python is a little
more succinct although a little less
explicit step by step you just do this
for I in range of 50 is the way of
saying start iterating at zero count all
the way up to but not including 50
thereby giving you a range of value so
this is the one that's perhaps the most
weird thus far but still a little more
succinct to write so in C we had so many
datatypes bool char double float int
long string the last of which of course
came from the cs50 library and there's
others that you can use in C as you
might recall from problem set 3 perhaps
in Python we're going to short in this
list at least initially to just these
data types in Python we're gonna have
bulls for true/false floats for real
numbers intz for integers and then
stirrers for Strings just a little more
succinct but it does actually exist
stir in Python is a real thing it is not
a cs50 addition there are other data
types that come with Python in fact this
is where the language gets powerful and
those of you who came from a Java
background or C++ those of the subset of
you who have programmed before you have
more features in Python just like you do
in those other languages that we did not
have in C in
Python you have dictionaries or hash
tables you have lists which are arrays
but that can automatically resize you
don't have to decide in advance how big
or small they are range we just saw it's
a range of values like 50 of them set in
the mathematical sense it's a collection
of things that ensures you don't have
duplicates in that collection and then
tupple is a combination of things kind
of like for math when you have X comma Y
or latitude comma longitude anytime you
have pairs or triples or more of things
those are called tuples and those are
common in math courses and higher-level
CS theory classes as well but we do give
you at least in this first week of our
look at Python a few functions from cs50
among them get float get int and get
string which behave exactly like their
SI counterparts and this is just going
to allow us to start writing code very
reminiscent of what we did the last few
weeks but let's consider what's going to
change as we're about to start writing
our own programs in C when you want you
to use the cs50 library you of course
included its header file that syntax is
going to change in Python so that for
this first week when you want to use the
cs50 library you're going to instead say
from cs50 import and then a comma
separated list of the functions that you
want to import or use in your code so
it's a little more precise this syntax
it's not saying give me everything give
me this
this and this other thing and if you
want to use one or more you can just
separate them by commas as an aside
especially those of you have seen Python
before there's other ways to do this
many there's several approaches this is
perhaps the most comparable for our
purposes today what else you're gonna
have to know in C you had to compile
your code and you did so with clang like
this and then you ran your program with
dot slash hello or more simply you did
make hello and then we figure out the
command for you in the IDE or the
sandbox or lab in Python you're gonna
skip the compilation step when you want
to run a program in Python you're gonna
do just what I did quickly before you're
just going to run the command Python and
then the name of the file that you want
to run and the reason for this is as
follows in the world of C recall that we
had this sort of pipeline process where
we have our source code as our input and
then we wanted to get to the point of
machine code the zeros and ones and what
was standing in between source code and
machine code
just to be clear what process yeah so
compiling so we had a compiler in the
middle whose purpose in life is by
definition to translate one language to
another it happens to be an English like
language to a computer like language but
a compiler is a general term that just
converts one thing to another and so
this pipeline for C looked like this and
that's why you had to run clang
explicitly or make you had to induce
that middleman operation to convert the
language to something the computer
understands Python and other languages
are not typically compiled in the same
way they're generally said to be
interpreted whereby you don't compile
them into zeros and ones and then run
the program you instead run a program
that someone else wrote called Python
and that program is by definition a
interpreter and that interpreters
purpose and life as the word implies is
to read your code top to bottom left to
right and just do exactly what you tell
it to do step by step by step without
doing the upfront work of converting
things to zeros and ones so in the human
world if I speak English and someone
there speaks Spanish and we don't speak
each other's language we might put a
third human in between us obviously a
human interpreter the role is very
similar
the interpreter listens to me and then
translates that to something the
computer understands but it doesn't get
into zeros and ones it just goes from
one directly to the other so the
difference here in Python is that you
still are going to write source code
like I quickly did for resize and
ultimately we want to actually get it
into a program called an interpreter and
so the step ideally just looks like this
but as an aside python is a pretty
sophisticated language and even though
we have the pleasure of running it just
with one step instead of these two steps
there actually is as an aside some magic
going on underneath the hood and for the
curious there actually is for
performance reasons a compiler built
into Python that actually converts it to
something intermediary called byte code
and byte code is what's actually
interpreted and so this is why Python
while potentially slower than C at
certain tasks because you're not going
to the low-level zeros and ones can
actually be used in business
applications and popular websites and
such and
really work very well and so it can be
highly performing as well but more on
that in a little bit so with that said
if this these are the differences not
only syntactically but also mechanically
let's go ahead and actually write a
program so let me go ahead and go into
the IDE let me close our examples from
before and let's start more simply
because resize was a mouthful all at
once let me go ahead and create a file
called hello dot pi and instead of
writing this program in C let me go
ahead and just write hello world so
let's go ahead and do this print hello
world done that's my first program in
Python and truly my first program in
Python not sort of coming out swinging
with resize so what is not present in
this file that was in something like
hello dot C there's no main function
necessary here what else is missing
there's no mention of printf it's
instead print which is a little more
human-friendly there's no mention of
header files or libraries at the top of
the file just I just dived right in and
got to it yeah
no semicolons what else what else yeah
no backslash-n I probably haven't run it
yet but I think I will get that for free
this time with Python I don't have to be
so explicit was there another hand here
there's no F in printf yep something
else there's no yeah there's no
indentation though to be fair there's
only one line but there's no indentation
that's fair that's fair
there's no curly braces as well there's
no mention of intz there's no mention of
void I mean my god like why didn't we
just do this last time and so this is
why languages evolved people realized
years ago like GC is serving as well the
fonts how you understand pointers and
the syntax okay I got it but my god it's
just so tedious to write even the
simplest of programs because I have to
do hash include standard IOH int main
void I mean all of this syntactic
overhead that's getting in the way of
you just doing the work you care about
which in simplest form here is just
printing HelloWorld so Python and a lot
of more modern languages among them Ruby
and PHP and others just get rid of a lot
of that overhead so that you can just
get down to work more quickly right away
so how do I go ahead and run this and
see recall I would have done like dot
slash hello dot pi but we just said a
moment ago that's not the right approach
how do I go and run this program yeah so
I run literally a program that is
coincidentally called Python itself that
is the interpreter that's the man in the
middle between me and my
spanish-speaking friends that just has
to convert hello dot pi into whatever
the computer itself understands and so
there indeed we have hello world and as
you notice there's no backslash n on my
code but I am moving the cursor to the
new line so Python just decided you know
what it's so damn common to have new
lines let's just add those by default no
the price we're gonna pay is it's a
little annoying to get rid of them but
we'll see that in a little bit too so
just a trade off all right let's do
another one that's just a simplest of
possible programs let's go ahead and do
say something a little fancier that
allows us to do something more than that
so let's go ahead say and compare not
just that but let's actually go get some
user input so for user input there's a
few ways to do this we'll do it the cs50
way initially but these are training
wheels this week that we'll use for just
a week before we take them off just
bridging us from C to PI
let me go ahead and call this string 0
PI because I'm dealing with strings and
let me go ahead and do s to give me a
variable getstring let me prompt the
human for his or her name like this and
then let me go ahead and say hello
so-and-so and now I just have to
consider how to print out their name and
in Python I can actually just do this I
don't need to do % s I don't need to put
a second or I do need put a second comma
here but I can just do this which is a
little simpler and this is not correct
I'm not practicing what I preached get
rid of the F just print what you want to
print indeed so s notice is apparently a
variable because I'm assigning it a
value from right to left but notice that
I'm not specifying the type so python
does have type stur we said is the
string equivalent but you don't have to
mention it Python like JavaScript will
just figure it out even without a
keyword like let but I do need to add
one thing what's that yeah getstring is
the cs50 thing and we're only going to
use it for a week but I do need to
import it in the syntax with which to do
this is to say from the cs50 library
import a function called getstring I
don't need to import anymore with commas
that one suffice is for this program
yeah
like not indicating
ah sure let me come back to this in one
second let's run this program first two
premise trait that indeed does what we
saw do last week and let me go ahead
here and do this time
Python of string zero let me go ahead
and it's just waiting for my name so
I'll type in David hello David but as
you propose what if you wanted to flip
this around well suppose I wanted to say
the person's name and then something
like hello because I'm just excited to
see them instead let's see what this
does let me go ahead now and run Python
of string zero type in my name and it's
almost what I think you intended but
there is a bug an aesthetic bug at least
so it seems with pythons print function
you don't need to use the placeholder
like percent s but it would seem to
presumptuously add a space for you after
everything you're passing in as an input
to print itself so notice print is
taking how many arguments according to
this highlighted portion how many
arguments might you infer s - yeah so -
one is s comma and then the rest is
what's highlighted in green here yes
there's a second comma there but it's
inside of the string so just I can see
that's sort of a red herring there's
only two arguments here but it seems
that the print function and you would
know this by reading that documentation
if you pass in two or three or more
arguments it prints all of them but
separates them with a single space so
this isn't quite right so this is
actually great motivation for cleaning
this up if I want to actually improve
this program and tidy it up a little bit
let me do that in version one here let
me create another file called say string
one dot pi let me start where we started
a moment ago and let me actually use a
placeholder akin to C so if I want to do
for instance hello so and so it turns
out you can actually say hey Python put
a variable called s right here however
if I run this as is they're still gonna
be a bug it's not quite solved yet when
I hit enter now and type in my name
alright this is obviously stupid-looking
so it seems that I need to tell Python
that this string that I'm passing in
hello comma so and so is a formatted
it's a placeholder stream that it should
make some changes to and this is a
little weird cryptic syntactically in
Python but the way you do this in Python
is you put an F before the string itself
so I'm sorry we should we got rid of the
F a moment ago so you just called it at
prints then we're reusing a different F
here and it's stupid-looking syntax
admittedly but this just means hey
python the following double quotes or
single quotes that you're about to see
should be formatted by you in a special
way and it literally goes at the
beginning of the string even though that
does admittedly look weird but if I now
rerun this Python string one and type in
my name now now it does the substitution
so I can flip it around logically much
more flexibly now and do something like
Hello because now I'm passing in one
argument that print will format for me
so when I type in my name now I'm not
going to get that superfluous space and
now I have complete control over the
formatting of the string so you know
sorry one two steps forward one step
back perhaps and tactically but it does
allow us to do what we want us to do we
could write the same program using int
and floats using get int and get float
would look exactly the same you don't
need to worry about percent s versus
percent I versus percent F you just type
in the variable name inside of those
curly braces alright let me go ahead and
do some quick math let me go ahead and
do this let me go ahead and create a new
file we'll call this in spy for integers
and let me go ahead and get this access
to how about the cs50 library's get int
method or function which exists then let
me go ahead and declare a variable
called X and get an int from the user
and just prompt him or her for X then
let me go ahead and do the same thing
and just get Y from them as well and
then down here let me just do some
simple math and we did this way back in
week one by printing as follows let me
go ahead and just print out X plus y
equals and this is what's cool now about
this curly brace feature you can
actually do not just variables names but
you can do simple operations in there
too I can literally do math inside of
those curly braces and print out that
value but of course this alone is just
gonna literally print the curly braces
what do I have to add yeah so it looks a
little weird but this now will solve
that problem it will print literally X
plus y
schools whatever the actual sum is
format format the following string for
me good question let's do just a few
copy-paste but change the operator here
so f X minus y I want to see what this
looks like X say what do we do last time
multiplying by Y I want to do that math
to I can divide as well and then we had
one more which was modulo or modular
arithmetic which recall was the % so
syntactically it's identical to see
we're just adding this curly brace
notation just for the print function
right now let me go ahead and run this
python of in stop hi and let me go ahead
and do one and say 2 so 1 plus 2 is 3 1
minus 2 is negative 1 1 times 2 is 2 1
divided by 2 is 0.5 and 1 then divide by
2 and take the remainder is 1 so I think
this checks out mathematically but you
should be a little surprised by one of
these outcomes
Segan yeah I'm getting a float like
Python itself seems to affixed a bug in
C itself what happened in C when you
divided one in integer by 2 an integer
in C you would get another integer and
what's the closest integer you can
represent that doesn't have a decimal
point 0 because C would truncate
everything after the decimal point and
yet Python seems to a fix this problem
and this is actually somewhat recent
phenomenon and this is a huge religious
debate as to whether or not you should
just keep the historical definition of
division which is floor division so to
speak or we should make it truly
division like we all grew up learning in
school Python took the latter approach
and made division mean division through
division where if you divide 2 inch you
get back a float of course this is a
problem if people want to write code
that assumes that it's going to be
truncated that can actually be a
powerful feature so it turns out and you
won't have terribly many occasions to
use this but the compromise in the world
was alright if you really want the old
behavior of the division in Python we
will give it back to you you have to use
two slashes so again another one these
two steps forward one step back but it's
there so
can still be solved in the same way and
this if I save it and rerun that same
code one and two and now I get back zero
just as I would in C which does have
some applicability let's do one other
example now involving some numbers and
let me go ahead and call this floats dot
pi and let me do the same thing from
cs50 import get float this time so I can
deal with floating point values let me
declare a variable X and get a float and
we'll ask the user for a variable X then
let's go ahead and get another float and
just as before call it Y but this time
both of them are indeed floats then let
me go ahead and do some math X plus y
equals Z to give myself a third variable
and then let me just go ahead and print
out a similar message X divided by y
equals Z all right and let me go ahead
and save this clear my terminal and do
Python afloat stop by 1/10 this time and
I get damn it bug how do I fix this all
right so just simple F make it a format
string no big deal so let's rerun this
one 10 okay whoo-hoo that's a new one
what is going on there
I did define Z in the line above it what
was your comment I did use X plus y but
I think I know I know okay I'm sorry
let's um you okay so if we can fix that
let's uh sorry there okay so 110 mmm
still wrong
good catch thank you though
why is 1 plus 2 11 or 1 plus 10 11 yeah
oh wait wait wait
sorry brings me back to my earlier point
us as to how tired I am so this is
correct so Python does Matt sure
correctly what okay horrifying all right
so now let's do division and try to make
the point I think I meant to make late
last night where if I do 1/10 ok 1/10 as
expected does actually work here so 0.1
that's correct but remember in C let me
dig myself out of this all remember and
see what happened if we dug a little
deeper and we looked a little past the
first decimal point so how do I do this
in Python it's actually pretty similar
let me go ahead and not just show myself
Z but go ahead and print out two let's
say two decimal places that same value
the syntax here is weird it's different
from C but you literally take the
variable that you want to format you put
a colon and then a dot because you want
to adjust the dot and then you want to
say something like 2 F so this is saying
hey Python format the variable that's to
the left of the colon using a two
decimal points and by the way it's a
floating point value so this F has a
different meaning this is F isn't float
the F to the left is in format so let me
go ahead and run this 1/10 and okay
still looking pretty good let's do maybe
three decimal places save that rerun it
1/10 still pretty good let's get a
little ambitious let's do it 50 decimal
places out 1/10 and damn it
Python has not fixed this fundamental
problem so we describe this problem as
what's the sort of buzzword here to sort
of explain or forgive this issue this is
an integer overflow related in spirit
integer overflow literally happens when
you're doing lots of addition and
something's rolling over from a big
value to a small or even a negative
similar in spirit yeah yeah if you want
to have an infinite amount of precision
all the way out you need an infinite
amount of memory and no Mac or piece of
your phone has an infinite amount of
memory at some point a line is drawn in
the sand and you can only be so precise
and so imprecision was the analog in the
floating-point world to overflow recall
where if you only have a finite number
of bits you can do really well up to a
point but eventually the computer's got
to estimate that value for it to you
because you can't represent an infinite
number of values so this is to say
Python is just as limited fundamentally
as some other languages like C so we've
not gotten rid of all those problems but
frankly in the world of data science and
analytics it's certainly important to
have precise mathematics so there are
solutions to this problem but it
requires special libraries typically use
importing something that allows you to
use as much memory as you want more than
just the default amount of memory so
that problem there still exists let me
go ahead and open up one other example
here and in fact in C you'll recall that
we had this example here in C we had a
program called overflow dot C and notice
that this code in C from a few weeks
back just multiplied I bye - bye - bye -
so it was doing exponentiation so to
speak 1 - 2 - 4 - 8 16 32 64 and so
forth what happened if we waited long
enough and watched this program a few
weeks back yeah we hit like roughly five
billion or four billion or rather we
technically hit I think 2 billion and
then it rolled over and it actually
created a problem so let me actually do
this let me go ahead and make overflow
so we can demonstrate the points that
you made earlier about integer overflow
which is indeed this one let me go ahead
now and run overflow I'll expand my
window just so we can fit a little more
in the screen and as this runs
whoops let me fix this here we go let me
go ahead and make overflow and now one
two four eight sixteen thirty-two and so
forth it's a little slow to start but
doubling and doubling is going to get us
up to a big value pretty quickly this is
indeed gonna overflow once we hit
roughly 2 billion why why 2 billion give
or take by that value in C yeah yeah
that's how much an integer can store
because we're calling C an INT is
typically 32 bits or 4 bytes and with 32
bits you can represent 4 billion
possible values and if half of those
values are positive and half of them are
negative it stands to reason that the
highest you can count is roughly 2
billion and indeed once we try to count
up just doubling 1 billion we overflow
so is your point at to your point
earlier overflow is still an issue but
in the context of integers but now let's
try a python version of this let me go
ahead now and open up overflow pi which
is a program I wrote in advance it's on
the courses website as always if you
want to take a look more closely and if
I go into this file in weeks one
overflow dot pi we see this code so it's
almost the same but notice I'm using
another library that we've not seen
before from time imports leap it's kind
of cute so this allows me to sleep for a
second that's going to get tedious
quickly but that's ok let's do this real
fast if I go into the source 6 directory
weeks 1 and run python of overflowed pi
it's the same function or same program
functionally but honestly this is
getting a little tedious let's go ahead
and not sleep for a second every time
save and reload let's just run the thing
whoa look at it go only up there look up
there what's it doing differently it's
counting a lot higher than 2 billions so
what might you infer about integers in
Python say again
okay the integer is defined to be quite
the number of bits and indeed that's the
case
the reason Python is not actually this
slow it's because we're running a
web-based IDE and the Internet itself is
a little slow and so what's happening
here is just the internet is getting in
the way but suffice it to say that
python is counting up way way higher
than c was and that's the power you get
by just using larger datatypes we could
have done this in c we could have used
longs for instance but notice that with
python you just give more by default out
of the box let's go ahead and take a
five-minute break here and when we
resume we'll introduce some more syntax
and solve some more problems all right
so let's take a look at a few other
examples that are comparable to what we
did back in week 1 and look at a few
from week 2 and 3 and really take a look
not just that the syntax ultimately but
some of the features of Python and of
course we need the ability to express
ourselves conditionally or logically
with control flow and so let me propose
a quick program here that we'll just
call conditions pi reminiscent of
conditions dot c some time ago let me go
ahead an import from cs50 get into this
time and get myself another X with get
int X from the user then let me go ahead
and ask them for get into Y from the
user and then let me go ahead and just
compare them and so per our comparison
would scratch a bit ago I can simply say
if X is less than Y then go ahead and
print out for instance print X is less
than Y just as we did weeks ago L if X
is greater than Y we can go ahead and
print out X is greater than Y and then
we can still have a third condition else
just I can see where we print out for
instance the logical conclusion X is
equal to Y so just to point out some of
the differences indentation is ever so
important now and it's got to be
consistent you can't have 4 spaces in 3
you've got to have for instance 4 all
the way notice that I've got the colons
consistently there but notice that I
don't need the parentheses either
anymore Python and with Python there's
sort of a buzzword pythonic there is a
pythonic way of doing things you can
have parentheses around X less than Y or
X greater than Y just like in C but it
doesn't add anything logically arguably
and if it doesn't make your code more
readable don't clutter your code with
additional characters and so that's a
general rule of thumb now python is much
more trim when it
comes to syntax only introducing it when
it really solves a problem which in this
case it doesn't really yeah
the lion suits em - those are grouped
right together one to the next one to
the next one to the next if you were to
put like an in traditional line between
that would that break the code no not at
all I can have as much white space
vertically as I want if I want to add
some comments indeed I can do that and
why don't we do that in fact because the
commenting syntax for Python is a little
different in C we were in the habit of
doing slash slash Python it's actually a
little more succinct you can just use a
single hash and you can say get X from
user here I can say get Y from user here
and then I can say something like
compare X and y and if I really wanted
to I could put comments in here that is
perfectly fine but I'll just keep it
more compact with this particular
example so any questions on the
conditional syntax or what we've just
done here all right let me whip up
another example this time doing some
comparisons this time let me create a
file called answer dot pi which is
reminiscent of a quick example we did
weeks ago called answer dot C let me go
ahead and from cs50 import get string
and this time let me go ahead and use
declare variable C and let me go ahead
and get a string from the user whoops
get a string from the user for their
answer to whatever question it is we
care about and then if it's meant to be
like a yes/no answer let's check for
that if C equals equals y or C equals
equals little Y then go ahead and say
just for the sake of demonstration yes
because the human presumably meant that
L if C equals equals n capital n or C
equals equals little n then go ahead and
print out for instance no so short
program but what's are some of the
takeaways well what's different clearly
among these lines 5 through 8 versus C
weeks ago yeah
yeah another stupid vertical bar so the
ampersand ampersand if you want to do
something or or and it together just say
and and or much like scratch actually
some weeks ago notice to how are we
comparing strings turns out Python does
not have chars per se see did have
charge single characters Python only has
strings and has strings in floats and
then some fancier things but it doesn't
have charge so that's why I'm
deliberately using string but when we
use strings and see how did we compare
two strings stir comp right because of
the whole annoying pointer comparison
thing well it turns out now in Python if
you want to compare two strings
character by character by character
equal equals is back and it does exactly
what you expect it to do even if it's a
full word so if you're actually checking
for for instance yes or yes from the
human you can still use equal equals as
well even though it's more than now one
character so that's a wonderful feature
too and it just makes the code more
readable and a lot easier to write right
out of the gate all right so now recall
that in PI and C we spent a little while
as well as in scratch taking a look at a
few examples about coughing of all
things and in fact in Python and C and
rather in scratching in C we did a zero
example that looked a little like this
if you want to simulate the notion of
scratch the cat coughing you might of
course do this and then if he's gonna
call three times you might do this and
we ran this and it just did coff coff
coff on the screen and won't bother
running it because it will just do that
but this was bad design we claimed weeks
ago what was the gist of why this is bad
design I mean I literally copied and
pasted it and odds are if you're ever
doing that in cs50 or in programming
more generally you're probably being a
little lazy and there's a better way to
do it and it's more maintainable way to
do it so of course we introduced weeks
ago both in scratch and in C the ability
to in coughed won this time do a loop
and I can do a loop slightly differently
in Python in and C but for I in the
range of three go ahead and print out
Koff so the syntax for the for loop is a
little different but it's pretty
straightforward nonetheless once you
remember that you use for variable name
then the preposition in and then the
word range with a parenthesis and it's
the parenthesis and the value want to
care about but then we saw an
opportunity recall to actually abstract
coughing away right a coughing at least
in our textual form it's just an act of
printing something so we introduced in
version two some time ago the following
approach in coughed two I instead
defined a function called cough that did
the coughing for mean we've not seen
this yet in Python so how do you define
a function in Python called cough put
another way how do you make your own
custom puzzle piece just as we did in
scratch
well you define it with death and then
you have it do exactly what you want it
to do by just indenting the lines of
code that belonged to that function so
there's no return value there's no need
for an input at the moment but we do
have the colon and we have the
indentation no curly braces nothing else
how do I now use this function well
here's where we have a few options
stylistically in the program the
simplest way to call this function would
be quite simply like this go ahead and
for I in range 3 go ahead now and COFF
and this should look a little weird it
looks indeed a little sloppy but let's
see if it works so if I go ahead and run
Python of coughed to dot pi it seems to
coff coff coff but i say this is a
little weird because what am i doing
that's very different now from see
there's no what there's no main function
I just have some code right here on the
left of the screen and yet I do have a
function here and in Python this is okay
because you're using an interpreter and
reading the file top to bottom left to
right you don't strictly need a function
called main it's just gonna interpret
all of your code and when it scenes the
definition of a function okay it's gonna
say okay got it I now know what the verb
COFF means I will do this anytime I see
it down here but we're gonna run into a
problem and if indeed I did what my
first instinct was was which was to put
my the logic the main part of my program
at the top and to define coughed down
here let's see what happens let me zoom
out let me go ahead and rerun cough to
dot pi and now we start to see the first
of our error messages and they're gonna
look just as cryptic at first glance as
as a clang and make work rest assured
that help 50 can help with Python error
messages as well
let's just try to parse what I do
understand coughed up High Line 2 and
module whatever that is a name error
name COFF is not defined so what's your
gut here what is that really what's the
explanation for that error because
coffees clearly defined literally with
the define def verb right there on line
for now what yeah I'm trying to call it
before it's defined Python is trying to
take me very literally and it's gonna do
top to bottom left to right and if it
doesn't see until the bottom something
it's supposed to be doing at the top
it's just not going to work so there is
a solution to this and it starts to get
a little ugly but it's a more
generalized solution it turns out that
even though main is not required in a
Python program many programmers just
create one nonetheless to address this
particular problem and they specifically
do something like this def main and then
below it they indent everything there
and then you need one specific feature
to solve this problem now I've now
defined main and I've defined coffee
which theoretically solves this problem
just as it did in C I don't there is no
notion of a prototype in Python that is
not the solution to copy/paste the name
of the function up above but when I do
this now literally nothing happens but I
did get rid of the error so just reason
through this perhaps especially if
you've never programmed Python before
why might nothing now be happening not
calling main yeah so whereas in C and
frankly in Java and a few out C++ and a
few other languages main is special it
just gets called by default in Python
main is not special I've chosen this
name main just because so many other
languages use it but it has no special
significance if you want to call main
you have to do it yourself and so this
is a little weird admittedly but you can
literally do this down here because your
code will be executed top to bottom left
to right by the timeline 10 is reached
both main has been defined and COFF has
been defined which means you're good to
go
so if I now go down here and run Python
of coughed 2 now it actually works now
as an aside this is not a pythonic if
you will most people would actually do
this if the name equals equals main
then do this this is for lower-level
reasons that let me wave my hand at for
today but long story short the addition
of this cryptic looking line solves
other problems that we're just not going
to trip over this weekend probably next
so this is the common way to do it but
if you just ignore that the effect of
this cryptic looking code is just to
call main yourself at the very bottom of
your file so when we start writing more
interesting programs this is just going
to become conventional if you want to
start writing functions and so forth
odds are you'll benefit by writing a
main function and putting more code in
there so let's do one final example with
coffee that actually now parameterize is
the code just as we did weeks ago in
scratch and see this will be coffee
three pi let me start as I did just a
little bit ago but suppose I want to
achieve this effect I want the computer
to COFF three times by passing in an
input I now do need to modify COFF to
take an input and in C I would have said
something like int n but you don't have
to specify data types in Python you just
have to specify the parameter name or
the argument name so that's nice and
simple and now down in here in coffee is
where I should probably say for I in the
range of three do this but this isn't
quite right what's fixed do I want to
make here yeah now I can just pass an n
so range is just a function that takes
an argument that I've been hard coding
is three just because but you can
generalize it within as well so now
again per our discussion of abstraction
weeks and weeks ago do we have a sort of
beautiful version of coughing even
though it's looking way more cryptic but
by step by step by step did we get to
the point of having a main function that
takes an abstraction cough do it this
many times now the implementation
details are hidden in this custom puzzle
piece if you will and the whole lot of
the two lines at the bottom just kick
off the whole execution of the program
but that's the only stuff that's really
Python specific now yeah
could use wit line the COFF function on
line 11 yes you could absolutely just do
this for instance and get rid of main
again it's just a convention once you
start writing more specificity cated
programs with functions that you should
probably introduce main just to keep it
tidy you come you could do that then
you're starting to be non pythonic like
yes you could do
Koff 3 but people would look askew at
you because it's just not done that way
that's what pythonic means yeah other
questions
not in this case so the order now is
okay
because first Python is seeing here's
the definition of main okay I got it
and then it's saying here's the
definition of Koff okay I got it but
it's not actually calling those
functions yet the Python errors are
thrown only at what's called run time
the running of the program's time which
means only when main is called does
Python actually execute line four and
then see ooh I need to call a function
called COFF but that's okay
because it saw it earlier when it first
read the file top to bottom so it
matters when the functions are called
not where they appear per se in the file
the order in which they're called other
questions all right yes how did I define
n is an integer this is what's nice
about Python if you want a variable or a
parameter just start using it without
mentioning its data type so the fact
that I put in in parentheses in this
function means hey Python let this
function take an input called n and it
can actually be any data type in float
string or even something else it's up to
me to use it responsibly as a number and
to call it responsibly with a number
good question yeah
is indeed possible for a variable to
change type a good observation
so yes python is not a strongly typed
language so to speak C is strongly typed
in that if you make something and in it
is staying an int forever
Python is loosely typed whereby X can be
an int initially but if you really want
to turn it into a string you can but the
the convention there would be yes you
can do that but don't do that
so python has the frankly the sort of
arrogance of being sort of an adult
language like yes you could do that but
just don't like why do we have to
protect you from yourselves and so in
that sense you need to be a little more
responsible about it but again there are
arguments both ways that reduces
potential bugs that C would catch for
you and this is where humans start to
disagree about the upsides and downsides
of languages whether a language should
be strongly or loosely or not even typed
at all good observation so let's look at
a paradigm that was super common in
see when we wanted to do something again
and again to see how it actually is a
little differently done in Python now
let me go ahead and declare pot uh
create a file called positive PI and go
ahead and write a program a little
quickly here so from cs50 let me go
ahead and import get int so we can get
integers from the user let me go ahead
and define a main function that simply
does I which will be my variable gets a
positive int and asks the user just as
we did weeks ago if you recall for a
positive integer and then just goes
ahead and very boringly prints it out so
that's all this program does and let me
go ahead and just from recollection
though it's totally fine to copy/paste
this cryptic looking string we would
just be remiss in not showing you how
most people do this so if i do this this
is a complete program except for the
fact that what does not exist yet get
positive int probably does not exist
just as it didn't in week one because we
have to invent it ourselves get in
exists but get positive int does not and
just for demonstration sake let's try
this python a positive pi notice we have
name error get positive int not defined
okay so we can fix that we can literally
define or def it so get positive int
it's gonna take a prompt from the user
just as it did weeks ago the string that
you want to show to him or her and now
let me go ahead and get a positive
integer what type of programming
construct did we use in c to do
something again and again and again a
loop for sure but more specifically to
do something at least once and then
maybe again and again and again if they
don't cooperate do-while
no do-while and python so that handy
feature for user input does not exist so
that's fine we need to solve this just
differently and honestly in c you could
have solved that problem differently you
don't need do while we could have taken
it away from you see could take it away
you could still solve every problem that
we have in the past weeks using a for
loop or a while loop through while just
is a nice handy feature but we can
simulate it and the pythonic way of
doing this is as follows deliberately
induce an infinite loop because you do
want to loop potentially but the logic
is going to be give me an infinite loop
and i will break out of it when i'm
ready to break out of it this would be
the convention so while the fall
is true do this go ahead and declare a
variable called n get an int from the
user and pass in that same prompt so get
in we wrote the staff prompt is whatever
I typed in up here so just copy/paste
from the C version and then under what
circumstances do I want to break out of
this infinite loop if the function is to
be called to get positive int yeah so if
n is greater than zero then I do have
the keyword break still just as I did in
C I can break out of this loop and then
once I do that I can go ahead and just
return n or for that matter I could
condense this a little bit I could just
return and immediately and tighten it
just a little bit so multiple ways to do
this otherwise it's just going to loop
and loop forever so let me go ahead now
and run positive dot pi through Python
positive integer like negative 1 maybe
negative 2 0 okay 1 and now it indeed
cooperates so this is just a common
paradigm and this is the kind of thing
when learning a new language that
honestly tends to hang people up
initially you need to learn the
JavaScript way of doing things you need
to learn the Python way of doing things
but then you start to notice these
so-called design patterns anytime in
Python you want to do something again
and again yes you want to loop but if
you want to do something maybe
definitely once and maybe again you
still just use a loop but you
deliberately induce
typically an infinite loop and just
break out of it when you're ready so a
very common approach
so not everything translates literally
from C back and forth any questions then
on that yeah back
really good question was is this
approach preferable to instead declaring
maybe hint here a variable that is equal
to some known value like zero or whatnot
and then updating it should answer yes
because your approach while correct is
not as well designed arguably because
it's just not necessary
and the pythonic way and really the in
the well-designed way to do most things
would be used as few lines as you can so
long as it's still readable and
understandable which I would argue this
is once you're comfortable with the
syntax but this does bring up an
interesting point about one other topic
in C scope has now gone out the window
at least as we previously saw it
scope refer to where a variable lives
and we defined it essentially casually
between two curly braces the most
recently open curly braces well no curly
braces anymore so it turns out that
variables by default have function scope
here so when you declare n on line 9 you
can use it in Python on line 10 and you
know what you can even use it on line 12
even though it was declared inside of
this loop higher up so once you declare
a variable on this line you can use it
anywhere on the subsequent line within
that same function so in some sense it's
a little sloppy that you're allowed to
do this but on the other hand it's very
convenient because you don't have to
deal with those things like declaring
the variable up here just to use it down
here so it's one less thing to think
about all right let's take a look just a
few examples from week two wherein we
introduced arrays and strings more
generally to see what has changed now as
well you'll recall that in week two
perhaps we had an example about
capitalization and let me go ahead and
look at the second version of that
capitalized - but convert it to Python
the purpose in life was to take input
from the user and just capitalize every
character therein so if I tip in my name
in all lowercase it should come back as
all uppercase so from the cs50 library
let me go ahead and import get string so
that I have some input from the user
then let me go ahead and just get a
string from the user like their name and
then I want to go ahead and capitalize
everything so let me go ahead and do
this and this is a fancy feature in C I
would have done like a for int I is 0 I
less than sterling I mean you perhaps
remember the paradigm for iterating over
string
pythons just so much more pleasant for
see in s that will induce a loop over
the string s giving you access to every
character at a time calling that
variable C and so what is it I want to
do just as a preliminary step a baby
step if you will let's just print out C
just to see what happens let me go ahead
down here and do Python of capitalize -
let me go ahead and type in my name all
lowercase alright and why is it showing
up vertically like that one character
per line now you get the free line free
new line this time so let's see how you
can disable that it's stupid looking
honestly but you say and the equals
quote unquote thereby revealing a new
feature of Python that C does not have
it turns out that python has not only
positional arguments as its called
whereby you just pass in arguments
between commas that's what we've been
doing in C but Python also has named
arguments whereby you can specify the
name of the argument than an equal sign
then the value and the power of named
arguments even though this is a tiny
example means that you can sometimes
pass in your arguments in any order you
don't have to remember you don't have to
pull up cs50 manual or the man pages to
remember what is the order of all these
darn arguments you can pass them in in
any order but by specifying the name of
the argument and equal sign and its
value and in Python too you can have
optional arguments obviously in all of
the examples thus far I have never typed
the word end and an equal sign yes but
what Python does support is default
values for arguments and so if you look
in the documentation for Python this is
equivalent this cryptic looking sequence
this is equivalent to the default
behavior which is to type none of that
at all and in reply implies for the
print function that you should end every
line with that default character
therefore if you want to override it you
can just change it to the empty string
quote unquote so if I now run this again
and run it through with my name now I
get it
like that one character at a time but
you can do weird things like hahahahaha
not that you would I don't know why you
went with that but I mean that does the
exact same thing because you're just
changing the line ending so
don't do that but do something else like
this with it instead so suppose I want
to now capitalize the first character it
turns out that strings in Python are
more powerful than strings in C and C
there is no string right that was a lie
it's just a sequence of characters as
referenced by an address in memory in
Python a string is an actual object it's
a data structure and if you think about
see we had structs toward the very end
of our look at C nodes and structs and
student structures and like a string in
python is like this container inside of
which somewhere are all of those
characters but in that container or
structure is also built in functions
features of a string that you can just
call so in C we would have said
something like two upper and then passed
as input to a function called two upper
the character that we care about Python
kind of flips the logic around strings
come with built-in functionality that
allow you to operate on the given
character automatically so in Python the
syntax is actually the character itself
use the dot notation because it's a
structure and then you can literally do
up oops
you can okay so you can literally do
upper so this is to say built into the
string type in Python is a bunch of
features one of which is a function
called upper and the syntax which you
call it is the name of the variable or
the name of the string dot name of the
function open paren close paren and
that's just now the paradigm there's no
C type library there's no two upper or
two lower those features now built into
the strings themselves and this is an
example of encapsulation or more
generally object-oriented programming
something you'll explore if you take a
class like cs50 one that bakes into the
data types itself all of the rail
relevant functionality it does not
relegate them to another library so if I
clean this up by just moving my name
moving the cursor to the next line now
hopefully you'll indeed see David typed
out in all caps the same idea as before
what about this length of a string this
one's pretty trivial but if I go in here
let me go ahead and create a file called
sterling of dot pi if I want to see the
length of a string from cs50 import gets
string just as we did before let me go
ahead and get a string for myself like
my name again and then here if I want to
print the length of the string in Python
you and see you would say sterling in
Python it's a little different you
actually just say Len for length so if I
go ahead and run this through sterling
sterling type in my name hopefully I
indeed see five and there's no notion
that you need to care about like the
backslash zero in order to terminate the
string yeah no in fact so that's a
really good observation let's rewind and
actually improve upon this rather than
just translate it from what was our
comparable example in C let me go ahead
here and actually say you know what s
gets s upper and then let me just print
s perhaps let's see what happens let me
go back here and run Python if
capitalized to enter David and it
operates on the whole string good
intuition and honestly I don't need to
do this I could just say to a rather
upper here and really trim this down and
do Python of capitalized type in my name
that still works and if I really want to
be fancy I don't even need s at all I
can take this get rid of that put this
here immediately call upper on the users
input and Whittle this down to a
one-line type in David and that to works
so you just get lots and lots and lots
of more expressiveness good question so
how do you even know that things like
this exists well quick aside Google will
truly be your friend in cases like this
and you'll want to know at this point
there's different versions of Python the
world is kind of holding out and is
still using a lot of people version two
of Python which is older by many years
now we are using version three and this
is where the world is going and indeed
Python two will be officially deprecated
or phased out in a couple of years
theoretically so when you google you
just want to be mindful of this so that
you don't accidentally make your way to
Oh to toriel's old documentation and the
like so let me go ahead and google
Python three string or stir and upper
just to see if I can get to the
documentation here you have a number of
tutorials but if we focus down here what
you're generally going to want to look
for at least for the official
documentation is docs Python org you see
in the URL it's version three and that's
where we want to go
so let me go ahead and click on this
common string operators and I will
disclaim this I think personally pythons
documentation is not terribly newbie
friendly like it's written fairly arcane
ly and you kind of have to really dig to
understand certain things that's fine
you'll get comfortable with it over time
but if you're feeling a little
overwhelmed by oh my god I just want to
know about upper like everyone feels
this way - so ctrl F for command F is
your friend upper let me go ahead and
search for this and it's not actually on
this page is it string string method
here we go
string methods okay so under string
methods let me go ahead and search for
upper and down here indeed is the
documentation so the convention will be
the name of the data type in question
stir for string the name of the function
here it would tell you in parenthesis if
it takes any arguments but it doesn't
and so it returns a copy of the string
with all of the cased characters
converted to uppercase that just means
the letters of the alphabet essentially
and then some additional documentation
and so forth it gets pretty low-level
pretty quickly these are the equivalent
of the man pages and there is no cs50
reference for Python that was just for C
so just realize that there's this
documentation available and you'll
notice there's bunches of functions
strip is actually kind of a popular one
or else strip or are strip if you have
white space at the beginning or end of a
line because you're human got a little
sloppy or there's new lines in a file
you can call strip on a string and get
rid of whitespace to the left and right
to kind of clean it up terribly useful
for things like data science
applications and analysis of data where
you just kind of clean up messy data so
many functions like that are built-in
for you all right so let's take a look
at a few other examples reminiscent of
features we did have in C such as this
one here suppose I want to write a
program that takes command-line
arguments much like resize with which we
started today's story from cs50 rather
let's not even use the cs50 library
let's do this if you want access to argh
fee recall and see it looked like this
int argc string Arg V it looked like
this in C well unfortunately if you're
not using main it would be nice if you
can still use command-line arguments and
you can but you have to import them it's
a library that provides you with access
from the sis or system library you can
or Arg V and Python and that gives you
access to command-line arguments as a
feature then you can say something like
this if the length of Arc V which is
just an array recall in c equals equals
two then go ahead and say hello and
let's go ahead and print out whatever
the user typed in Arg V one else let's
just by default say hello world so in
English what's happening if the user
typed in a command-line argument say
hello so-and-so else if the human did
not type in exactly one command-line
argument just say by default hello world
so let me save this do Python of arc v1
or rather 0 enter okay I didn't type in
a word after the command so now let's do
it again and I'll type in Brian's name
enter hello Brian let's do it again
Veronica Veronica enter now there's
something that's not quite the same as
see how many words did I just type at
the prompt 3 so that would suggest that
this is our v-0 v1 and our v2 and yet
I'm printing Arg v1 not arg v2 so how do
I think about this the codes correct but
it's different from C what does Arg V
technically store when you run a command
like these remember let's rewind in Sea
Org v-0 stored what the name of the file
or the name of the program you just ran
notice though the program I just ran is
called Python and so you would think
that our v-0 would have Python in it but
it doesn't because notice if I'm
printing our v1 you would think that's
0-1 you would think I just said hello
argh V 0 dot PI but I didn't argh b1 I'm
clearly in prints Veronica or Brian so
that it stands to reason organ be 0 is
this which means this is like art v- 1
python is excluded from the argument
vector as it's called the command-line
arguments do not include the name of the
interpreter but otherwise it works
exactly the same as it did once upon a
time and notice too with this new for
construct notice what you can do
whenever you have access to an array of
things
if I go into aargh v1 dot pie and import
argh V again let me go ahead now and
just you know what 4s in argh V go ahead
and print out s it's really succinct
what is this going to do let me go ahead
and do Python of Arc v1 enter and it
just prints out the name of the file if
I go ahead and say foo bar Baz three
random words it prints out all of those
words and so what's powerful about
Python is honestly this for loop there's
no int I less than plus plus any of that
you just say give me a variable called s
and iterate over the entirety of the
thing on the right which is presumed in
this case to be an array you can be even
more powerful than that if I just like
in C weeks ago look at characters in
these strings let me do arc v2 dot I
suppose that this iterate over each
string in art V and then here iterate
over each character in s I can do for C
in s and now print out the character so
now when I run this same command but on
argh v2 dot I notice what's gonna happen
let me raise this a little bit enter it
prints every character from every word
one at a time but it did so this time
based on using these two for loops so
what does this mean when you have an
array as we've called it you can iterate
over everything in the array when you
have a string you can iterate over every
character in the string and this is
where Python just gets wonderfully
flexible to do this again and again
alright let's take a look at let's see
compared strings already we copied
strings let's go ahead and do this in
Python
recall that we ran into like a
fundamental limitation of C and it would
seem programming when we had example
called swap and no swap back in the day
where I was just trying to swap two
values x and y and recall that i
hard-coded something like X is 1 and Y
is 2 and the whole goal was simply to
first say X is such and such
y is such and such let me go ahead and
make that a format string then I wanted
to print this again but somewhere in
here I wanted to swap X and Y so to
punctuate our sort of X
flourishing of just what Python can do
if you want to swap two variables x and
y that's fine just do it and it's this
magical shell game that just works in
Python now technically these are what
are called tuples on the left
it's a X comma Y pair its latitude comma
longitude so there's an actual
underlying mental model for what's going
on here but in effect you're literally
switching them and you don't need the
temporary variable Python the language
takes care of that for you all right
let's look at a more powerful feature
still this time using but what's
actually called a list so a moment ago I
was using Arg V 0 1 2 as our examples
and I was calling them our arrays
they're not arrays anymore Python does
not have arrays Python has lists and
lists sounds reminiscent of linked lists
and indeed they are in Python you have
lists that are resizable you don't have
to decide in advance how big they are or
how small they are they will just grow
and shrink for you just like a linked
list will but you don't have to write
the linked list yourself yeah sure
oh sure let me open that file up in rv1
this one here oh this one here yes you
can still show Arg V I called it an
array but that was a white lie a moment
ago it's actually a list a linked list
but whereas a linked list in C does not
allow you to use square brackets you
have to use a for loop or a while loop
to iterate over the whole thing to find
what you're looking for in Python if
something is in a list you can just use
yes the square brackets to get at that
specific element oh I could have yes I
didn't use the F just because frankly I
say it just gets ugly eventually but yes
I could have also done this to achieve
the exact same effect it just starts to
look cryptic okay
so let's actually introduce a list which
itself is a data type in Python as well
as in languages like C++ and Java if
some of you have that background as well
so here in list dot pi let me go ahead
and do the following let me first import
from the cs50 library get int so that we
can get some int from the user let me
give myself an array
aka now a list in Python so in C you
can't really express quite this idea in
Python if you want a variable called
numbers and you want to initialize it to
an empty list you just literally do Open
bracket close bracket no number in
between them and as before no semicolon
let's now do the following forever until
I break out of this let me go ahead and
get a number from the user just by
asking them for some number then let me
say if not number go ahead and break out
of this this is going to as an aside
just let me quit out of this by hitting
ctrl D as we discussed ever so briefly a
while back but that's just a UI feature
so this is what's kind of cool suppose I
want to implement the notion of checking
if this lit the number of the users
typed in is in the list already and if
so not at it I'm gonna go ahead and do
that but first let's just do this
numbers dot append number and this is a
new feature so what do I want to do here
for number in numbers and I'll explain
this in a second let me go ahead and
print number so what is this program
aspiring to do at the
very top I'm importing get in the very
top below that I'm just giving myself an
empty array now called a list called
numbers then I do the following forever
go ahead and get the number from the
user if he or she did not actually type
in a number just break out of this the
program is done but here's the new
feature just as with strings they are
objects so to speak they are data
structures that have functions built-in
so do lists have functions built in
there is literally a function inside of
every Python list called append that
literally does that you call append and
it depends whatever its input is to
whatever the list itself is so in C you
might have had to use on realloc you
might have had to add something to the
end of the list none of that happens
anymore just at a high level you say
append this to the list and let the
language take care of it for you then
down here I left aligned all the way at
the end it's just saying for numbering
numbers like iterate over all of the
lumbers in the list and print out one at
a time so let's try this let me go down
here and do python of this is list op hi
and let me go ahead and type in a number
like 13 42 50 and I'm gonna hit control
D which means that's it I'm done and
there we see the three numbers it looks
a little stupid because you know what I
think I need a a print here let's fix
this let me rerun this 13 42 50 control
D there we go one per line but what this
program has is honestly kind of a bug
potentially suppose I want unique
numbers now I have three 13s but ideally
just want one copy of every number for
whatever reason I want uniqueness well
notice how easily you can express that
what if my goal is to only conditionally
add a number to the numbers list if it's
not already there how would you do this
in C you have an array called numbers
and you want to first check is a number
in that array what would you do in
English a for loop right you probably
start at the left iterate over the whole
array looking for the number and then
conclude true or false it's in there
it's not hard but it's a little annoying
if they write more code couple lines for
lines for a for loop in Python just say
what you mean if number not in numbers
appended and it reads much more like in
glitch it's at the
the day some human wrote the for-loop
that does that operation but we the perp
more modern programmers can just now say
if number not in numbers append it and
so it is meant to read more English like
so let's try this now thirteen thirteen
fifty done now I just get one copy of
the thirteen because it's checking that
for me now running time is still an
issue consider this theoretically you're
still wasting some time looking for a
number because someone wrote code that's
probably linear search maybe it's binary
search if it's sorted but someone wrote
that code but the point is with these
higher-level languages these more modern
languages like Python that is not our
problem necessarily it only becomes our
problem if the program is just too slow
for some reason and we really need to
get into the weeds of why all right
let's look at a final feature
syntactically before we try this to a
more generalized problem let me go ahead
and save a file called struct 0 dot I
which is reminiscent of struct 0 dot see
a few weeks back and let me go ahead and
from the cs50 library import get string
let me go ahead and give myself an array
this time called students that's empty
or a list called students and then let
me just get three students for the sake
of discussion so for I in range three
that just iterates three times let me go
ahead and ask the user for their name so
get string ask them for their name then
let me go ahead and ask them for their
dorm and go ahead and get string for
dorm and then that's enough let me now
go ahead and append the student to my
list
so students dot a pen but I don't really
have a student structure yet now there's
many ways we could solve this but let me
propose the simplest one it turns out in
Python you can declare hash tables so
wonderfully simply a hash table is just
a collection of key value pairs and I
would argue at this point in my example
I have keys and values I have a name
which is a key and the value like David
or whatever
another key called dorm and then a value
which is like Matthew's or wherever and
so keys and values so it would be kind
of nice if I could create for myself
like a hash table or even a try for that
matter that allows me to store this data
well it turns out in Python I can do
just that I can go ahead and create an
object called student using curly break
bracket notation and you can literally
do this
the name shall be one key and now it's
gonna take on that value dorm shall be
another key and it's gonna take on that
value so I could call this anything I
want X&Y and have the values David and
Matthews or whatever it is I'm going to
type in but if you want a very
generalized data structure that isn't
just a list of values from left to right
but has metadata a key or like if you
think of a spreadsheet a column name
called name and a column name called
dorm each of which has values you just
use curly braces and you put the keys in
quotes and then a colon and then if
you've got multiple keys you just put a
comma so it's a little cryptic but this
is just like a container a hash table
that contains words and values now in
pset four when you implemented speller
you actually just said yes or no is the
word in the dictionary but you certainly
could have stored more information
instead of just boolean values you just
tended to not need to do that so what
does this mean for me at this point in
the story I have an object as it's
called in Python that stores these keys
and these values so if later on I want
to iterate over them I can do this for
student in oh you have to append it so
students dot append student let's add
the student to the list so for student
in students which is just how you
iterate over every one of the things in
that list let me just go ahead and say a
sentence like I want to say so-and-so is
in this dorm so how do i express that
well so-and-so I need to get access to
the student's name and the way I can do
this is as follows I could say let's go
ahead and say curly brace student
bracket name close bracket and then here
I can go ahead and say oops let me put
quotes in here and then here I can say
student bracket quote unquote dorm so
this is admittedly the most cryptic
example we've done thus far but let's
tease it apart as a format string so if
i zoom in on this what am i doing the
curly braces and the F just means format
this string so you can ignore the curly
braces as part of our story from earlier
student is the name of the variable in
the for loop so it's the current student
the square brackets are new in C the
only time we use square brackets was in
what content
a raise and what did we always put in
those square brackets a number yeah so 0
1 2 you can index into an array
what's cool about an object or hash
table more generally as we're now
defining it is you can index into the
variable using not numbers but words so
you could think of student as being like
a list or an array with two values name
and dorm but it's nice to be able to
refer to those not as 0 and 1 or some
stupid arbitrary number but rather by
keys name and dorm so this syntax here
though cryptic says go inside the
student object and get me the value of
the key called name and this is the same
thing about dorm so a an object in
Python or more generally a hash table
allows you to associate keys with values
and this is quite simply the syntax you
use for that so let me go ahead and run
this struct 0 dot I type in my name
let's save Matthews let's do like
Veronica weld
let's do Brian Brian where'd you live my
freshman year Pennypacker enter not that
they specifically really matter but now
we've expressed all of these sentences
so the short of it now is we didn't
quite see this in C but we did see a
hint of this when we implemented our own
hash table in C so that we can actually
access keys and values arbitrarily so
let's do a cup off here for any
questions before we bring back Mario all
right so let's now not just do examples
for the sake of demonstration but rewind
to an old friend that we've seen a few
times and just look at a few different
screens so in Super Mario Brothers
running left to right you might recall
or have seen that there's stuff like
this in the sky and Mario is supposed to
run under it and jump up and he gets
coins or whatever by jumping up and
hitting these question mark so this is
mostly a very contrived way of saying
suppose we want to print out for
question marks on the screen it just
like Super Mario Brothers how could we
do it it's gonna be a little black and
white a little textual but how do I
print out for question marks well let me
go over here and let me create a file
called let's say Mario 0pi and how do I
do this what's the simplest
way to do this print for question marks
okay I heard print okay for question
marks very good
so let's go ahead and run Mario zero
correct that's right so this is not bad
it's one string not a huge deal let's do
it at least with a loop as we've been
often doing just to improve the design
even though this is a very tiny tiny
tiny example so Mario one pie let's go
ahead and print this out with a loop for
instance so how do I do this how do I
print for question marks but one at a
time for I and yep range for print
question mark save alright so python
Mario's anyone want to yell it no don't
do that
okay okay thanks that's great all right
so why did you not want me to do that
because they're all vertical so we did
have a fix for this how do I tell print
and don't end your lines with the
default new line so end equals just
quote unquote to override the default
backslash end value so now I can rerun
this alright it's a little buggy so how
can I fix this and move only put a new
line after the last one yeah the
honestly just do print print nothing and
that will have the effect of printing a
new line for free so let's do this okay
now we've got a good example there all
right so it turns out we actually
printed along the way a separate example
which looked like this albeit with four
blocks so we won't let's go ahead and do
this now vertically not with question
marks but with hashes like bricks so if
we want to print out those three hashes
allow me to draw some inspiration from
this and let's say in Mario 2 dot pi let
me go ahead and just say for I in range
of three go ahead and print out just one
block and as you've been advising just
do this or rather nope let's use the
default to print out a vertical bar of
three blocks so this is Mario 2 dot pi
and now we've done something reminiscent
of that but now things get a little
interesting if we go underground and
let's focus on like this square so three
by three for instance because we've not
quite seen something like this so in our
last example here let's see could we go
to maybe a brave volunteer to come on up
tie up some of these ideas together is
that yeah hand back there come on down
so this will be Mario 3 dot PI the goal
of which is to print a brick a bigger
brick it's like three by three hello
again
for the audience what's your name Andrea
nice to see you alright so the goal at
hand is to print like a three by three
grid of just hashes reminiscent of those
bricks alright you're in charge whatever
gets the job done all right four okay
good
okay interesting okay print
quote-unquote Sprint's yeah okay key
detail a hash is fine yep
alright and before we do this do does
everyone want her to run this program
and be correct know why someone who
claims no what what's your concern
good okay so you fix that good any other
concerns yeah okay is it gonna go up and
down well let's see can you walk us
through verbally do we have do we have
can you walk us through with the program
does that happen then we print a new
line and then it should execute that
three times
all right what do you think do you the
duck is convinced all right why don't
you guys save the file let's try right
no harm in trying so right or wrong
let's see this is called Mario 3 PI and
I think we have a round of applause if
we could very nicely done
all right so let's end if you'd like one
more so let's take a look at one final
example coming full circle from where we
begin we of course looked at resize and
let's open that up just to see how I got
away with writing so little code and
actually getting that job done so in
resize dot pi which is where we began
notice that I had a few lines that
hopefully look a little more familiar
now but we didn't exactly introduce all
of these features ourselves so it turns
out in line 1 and line 2 we have one
unfamiliar and one familiar line line
two just gives us access to command line
arguments which we needed for resizing
the bitmap line one is ruler a lot of
the power is coming from it turns out
there's a library in Python called
pillow that you can install by typing a
certain command at your terminal it
doesn't necessarily come with your Mac
or PC you have to download it and
install it with a command and then if
you read it's documentation it will say
from pill for pillow import image now
that's not a specific image that's the
name of a library called the image
library that comes with that software
that someone freely made available so
that's just saying give me access to an
image related library and undoubtedly
there could exist similar things in C
but we've course did things very
hands-on low-level all right if the
length of art V is not for yell at the
user with the usage and that's just if
they don't cooperate by typing in as
they should this it's a little more
verbose now because we have Python and
we have the file extension but we could
technically clean that up if we really
wanted mine seven eight and nine there's
nothing really new there I'm just
declaring three variables implicitly
typed I don't have to bother saying int
or string I'm accessing Arg V one two
and three which is one two and three and
then I'm doing one thing on line seven
what is line seven doing that's
important I'm changing the argument from
what is technically a string by default
because indeed it came from the human
hands at a keyboard and converting it
into a number now as an aside if the
user does not provide a number like
two or 10 this code could break to be
fair I should really have some error
checking to make sure if the user typed
in hello and not two or ten I need to
catch that error so I'm being a little
sloppy but it was really meant to
demonstrate succinct code so now we have
in file an al file to find exactly as
before so we have just three lines left
that actually implement most of the
magic yeah
wait save the last bird again yes uh
good observation so this is not just
converting the users input to the
equivalent ASCII value because that's
not what we want this int you seer is
actually converting it as via a to I a
function that you probably used a couple
weeks ago it's just named a little more
succinctly there is a function via which
you could convert a character or string
to its ASCII equivalent but that's not
what's going on here it does the more
intuitive turn this into an integer
without using a cryptically named
function like a to I so let's scroll
down just a little further to these last
few lines and see what's going on some
of them you would only know how to do
from having read the documentation just
as we did this says give me a variable
called in image could have called it
anything I'm just trying to be
consistent within file this says use the
image library use its open function that
comes with it so image is some kind of
structure inside of which is some useful
image related functionality so call its
open function on the name of the file
then go ahead and extract its height and
width so turns out this is another
couple if you will tuples again are like
X comma Y latitude comma longitude you'd
only know that it is a tupple from the
documentation so when I say with comma
height this is taking what's technically
an array a list of size two we're really
a tupple and it's just extracting for me
the width and the height but let me wave
my hands at that particular syntax the
rest of this just is the following give
me a new variable called out image
called the input images resize function
another piece of functionality built
into it just like open and change it by
this width and this height the original
width times n the original height times
n no padding manipulation that's all the
responsibility of the library some other
human dealt with all of that for us and
this last line perhaps not surprisingly
saves the output image to that file name
so in just what 15 lines of code and
fewer if we get rid of some of the
whitespace can you implement the
entirety of resize but really focusing
on the logic of the problem I want to
take an input from the user
I'm going to scale it up by a factor of
n and I want to save out the file that's
what you care about you don't
necessarily care about getting into the
weeds of exactly what it was you had to
do when you did it you
see so let's do one final example here
you'll recall from problem set four you
implemented your own spell checker and
odds are you did a try or hash table or
the like and it turns out that is
non-trivial certainly in C and it's
non-trivial certainly for the first time
in any language but let me take a stab
at doing this now in Python let me go
into source 6 where I have a speller
example and notice that in this folder
today I've brought a few files with me
so I've brought a full copy of the
dictionaries from pset 4 I've copy of
the text files like la-la-land and the
like in text and then I brought two
files dictionary pie and speller dot pie
the latter of which is an implementation
of speller see in Python and I'm not
going to pull that one up because we
wrote that one entirely for you but let
me go ahead and write for instance just
my own dictionary so dictionary dot pi
is the analog of speller or up
dictionary dot C and let's go ahead and
and set this up let me go ahead and
create this file in a separate folder
for now so dictionary dot pi and there's
a few functions in dictionary C which we
should probably get around to
implementing what are those functions
load was one and load takes the name of
a file or a dictionary so let's do this
and I'll just say to do come back to
that what other functions were in
dictionary dot C check so def check and
what did check take is an input a word
yep so we'll come back to this and just
come back to that to do what other
functions size was one so def size this
did not take input but it just returned
the size of the structure so we'll come
back to that and lastly okay so unload
all right so this was this is the Python
version of the distribution code for
speller for your dictionary file so
unload also didn't take an argument so
that's something for us to do - so
what's the gist of making a spell
checker you are loading words in your
load function from a dictionary file and
the goal is to load those somehow into
memory you had a design decision for the
pset in C where you could make a hash
table or try or even a linked list or
even an array but odds are the first of
those two were probably more efficient
so it turns out that in Python you have
the ability to store words pretty
readily in any number of data structures
you have not just in sand floats and
strings but you clearly have lists as
we've seen
we call them objects or hashes hash
tables and there's other things too even
called sets where a set is kind of just
a collection of words which would be
very nicely searchable and so you know
what if I want to ultimately load some
words let me give myself a global
variable called words and just
initialize it to an empty set so I have
a global variable called words and
nothing is in it just yet but it's a set
of words how do I go about loading words
into that dictionary well let's go ahead
and implement load here so let me go
ahead and declare a variable called file
and open this dictionary in read mode
just as in C and then how do I iterate
over the lines in a file we've not seen
that but I do know how to iterate over
the strings in an array and the
characters in this string so let me go
with my instinct for line in file indeed
this will do exactly what you want it to
do then let me go ahead and add to my
words its data structure the following
line and then let me close the file and
then let me just say return true because
all is well done all right so I'm
cutting a few corners technically let me
use that function I alluded to earlier
let me go ahead and call our strip and
strip off the new line because in the
file technically when you're reading in
those words every line ends with a
backslash 0 that's not part of the word
so a minor correction there that I'm
stripping off the line but that's it for
a load how do I now check if a given
word is in that set well I can just say
if word in words return true else return
false done with check how do I return
the size of this data structure how
about I just returned the length of that
structure words and then unload heck
Python is doing this all for me done let
me shrink this and you know what this is
a little verbose I don't actually need
to do this if else I could just return
word in words and that will return a
boolean for me and honestly if I want to
lowercase it that's easy I can just do
this and take care of that and now it's
even better that's pset 5 you said for
excited wish we had done this in C so
what is the whole point of all of this
because the goal wasn't to sort of
create sort of great angst and
under now but the whole point of having
introduced to see over these past few
weeks is to one
none of this now do you take for granted
I mean you might be longing for having
implemented this in Python and you might
have had to read some documentation and
figure out the various syntax but my god
like I we whittled down what probably
took most of you hours into just seconds
once you're more comfortable with the
language but also to our very earliest
point today once you have the right
language and the right tool for the job
now it's not to say that this is perfect
because in fact let's go ahead and do
some tests let me go into my terminal
window here and I actually brought my
own solution in my C folder here let's
see I have my own code to speller
implemented in C here and let me go
ahead and run a test let me go ahead and
run speller on say the text Shakespeare
that's a pretty big input let's go ahead
and hit enter and this is my spell
checker running and all the words are
outputting in the time total to run
speller in C would say 0.9 seconds so
that's actually pretty good
in a second window let me go up here in
another terminal window and let me go
into today's code and into the speller
folder where I have a Python version
that I'm going to run as follow speller
pi let me go ahead and run it on
Shakespeare so we've not looked at
speller dot pi but it is essentially
line for line a port a translation from
C to Python but you're welcome to look
at that on line and it's using my
dictionary dot pi file let me go ahead
and run that it's running through all
the words top is Python bottom is C here
we go here we go there we go
now this is a bit misleading because
again the Internet is in the way we're
using a web based IDE and so it's funny
that that appears so many times and
you'll see it's not 10 20 seconds
however long that was that was just the
internet being slow and all we're timing
is your functions in both C and Python
but what's a take away between Python
and C same inputs
what do you say yeah uh yeah and I would
say concise that's more aesthetic it's
more well not even that I think they're
these are correct both of them are
correct like all of the important
numbers at the top are identical so but
what is clearly different though it's
slower so Python seems to be slower
right it takes in total if we just to
look at two numbers one point five five
seconds in Python if you ignore the
internet speed and just look at the code
performance versus point nine so it's
almost twice as slow as C so what's the
takeaway there well yes it took me you
know what 10 20 30 seconds to write the
code but it's taking me twice as long to
run it now not a big deal of course when
we're talking a few seconds here and
there but if this were a big data set
that you're analyzing for some project
or for work or for any kind of analysis
project and the data is much larger than
even this especially in the medical
field or the like maybe you don't want
to use Python sure you can bang out the
code in just a few minutes maybe a few
hours but once you run it damn is it
it's slower than using something like C
whereas in C might take you more time up
front and you might not even have the
comfort with C anymore so it's gonna
take you even longer because you have to
go relearn a language but when you run
it wow it runs twice as fast you
therefore need less RAM potentially less
hardware or less expensive hardware
because you can get away with more so
again this theme we keep seeing and data
structures and algorithms is trade-offs
like developer time is a resource and it
is wonderful that I and now you would be
able to write code so much more quickly
but you do have to pay a price somewhere
and there's clearly a price with Python
and it's not because python is poorly
implemented but what is the fundamental
difference between the paradigm of
programming and C versus in Python as
we've seen it today
what's different yeah
mm-hmm indeed and let me flip it around
so with C you're compiling down to zeros
and ones and that compiler is super
smart and it's gonna move things around
in memory it's gonna talk the computer's
native language of zeros and ones Python
is indeed reading your code by contrast
line by line top to bottom left to right
and even though technically underneath
the hood there is a compilation step
there's nonetheless some overhead
involved the mere fact that we're no
longer running clang and then getting
zeros and ones or running make and
getting zeros and ones that's great but
we have to pay the price somewhere so
this is gonna be thematic like there is
no Holy Grail among languages or tools
or techniques there's gonna be
trade-offs among your comfort your
familiarity or recollection of a
language how easy it is to use how
succinctly you can type it and then how
efficiently you can actually run it on
the screen and with C hopefully now we
will not write anymore C code you have
an appreciation in Python if when you
create a hash or a list rather or if you
create a set or a hash table or the like
which you're really getting access to is
someone else's implementation of pset 4
and pset 3 and pset 2 and pset 1 in some
form but now exposed to you in a more
powerful and more modern language so
let's end there officially today and
next week we'll do the same thing but in
the context of web programming